Unconditional surrender means foreign troops get to your wife
and daughter. Everyone can feel that. [laughter]
>> Shut up, Tucker. Shut the [__] up, >> I
think there's a chance that Trump just wants to like nuke some
[__] Just for the sake of it. Just be like, I'm the
guy who nuked.
People are so triggered by this Tucker interview. Tucker is triggering
the [__] out of people.
Tucker, Israel is one of the ugliest countries in the world,
which has built nothing of beauty since 1948. All their enemies
are beautiful and the IDF is determined to destroy beautiful
things. Look. So this is this is essentially what Tucker says.
And Hanania has the most insane insane response to it. Cuz at
worst, okay, at worst,
this is just racism.
But Hanania is like, look, this isn't a disagreement about policy.
There's nobody who talks like this. This is doesn't have genocidal
hatred in their heart. They're the enemies of all that is good
in his twisted mind.
I mean, no. I'm sure he's totally violent towards people in the
states. Israelis on the other hand, Israelis got some problems,
man.
But then Dude, this triggered people so much. And then I just
saw a whole bunch of people posting like architecture and stuff
in
It just looks so ugly as [__] It's like the most
It's the most It's just a ter
it's like a patchwork of
I don't know how to explain it. It's like so ugly. Like just
some random streets in Tel Aviv are like so ugly the way they're
laid out. The way that everything comes together.
They're like, Israel is a first-world country with a ton of money
put into it and it looks like a random third-world Latin American
[__]
Which sorry if you're from Latin America, okay?
It's unusually ugly for a rich nation and it's unfortunate. Tel
Aviv is super rich and still looks like some second-tier Latin
place. Most you who have any aesthetic taste, e.g. in urban design,
agree. But it's known you have zero aesthetic sensitivity, so
you can't parse this. You're This guy just called Richard Hanania
aesthetically
You have no aesthetic taste yourself, so you can't even understand
that this is gross. This is like a shit-looking city.
Why is one of the richest cities in the world looking like this?
What the What is this?
Like Tucker, you're a coward. You're driven by hate and want
to pretend this is a debate about architecture instead of owning
up to the fact that your
that your ideological is nothing but genocidal genocidal resentment.
Richard Hanania
I I dare say he looks lost. He's like kind of lost. I don't I
don't know what the [__] he's getting so mad about.
I agree, Tucker said something that was like a little over the
top, but like genocidal hatred?
Really gen- genocidal hatred? >> by Israel, which is one
of the single ugliest countries in the world. Nothing of beauty
has been built there since 1948. Sorry, I've been everywhere
in that country and it's true. Is it the nature of this emerging
empire is destructive?
And it always seems like beautiful things wind up being destroyed.
Europe,
right? Beirut,
parts of Syria, the holy
>> Okay, I will give
If you didn't have the context here for how this was going with
Tucker,
if you didn't have the context,
I do believe he generally argues that people caused the migration
to Europe and destroyed it.
Uh Lauren Southern seeming pretty vindicated, I don't know. At
least to a right-wing contemporary, she's got to be pretty vindicated.
>> sites I I don't Parts of Iran are apparently beautiful,
totally blown up. >> What better drama is there than Tucker
Carlson talked to free
Saagar Enjeti.
I don't know how to say his last name. I super don't care about
Tucker's monologue. I just want to get to the interview. I want
to watch a little bit of this. It's pretty good.
It's pretty good. Is America's sovereignty in
danger? Tucker, thank you very much for doing this. I've been
thinking of you. Let's start just with the overview. What have
you learned since this war began? Well, Tucker, unfortunately,
and I'm very sad to say this is that our very sovereignty is
in question right now. The Secretary of State made perhaps one
of the most remarkable statements of my entire life and perhaps
in modern history when he declared unequivocally that we are
involved in this war as a result of the either inability or the
adherence to an Israeli strike that was going to happen on Tehran.
This reveals a lot of different things about our government,
our structure. We were either unable to exert pressure on Israel
to avoid such a war, we either acquiesced to it, and both are
terrifying in their result because we are, of course, the global
superpower and Israel is a client state. I've also learned, very
unfortunately, having spent my entire career trying to trying
to repudiate the lessons of the Iraq war, of Syria, and of Libya
of an overwhelming propaganda effort on both sides, both parties,
the mainstream media, but still, unfortunately, very alive and
well, it seems, in the Republican Party and in the White House
cheering on regime change, demands of unconditional surrender
made
I I do think this is interesting, just getting like the right-wing
perspective on this. But so, Sagar and Tucker are both ostensibly
right-wing. It's very interesting to hear them talk about it.
Like, if you think things are [__] if any liberal
thinks that like, again,
Hasan is bad. But, while Hasan is bad, to compare him to like
a Fuentes, a Tucker, or just generally on the right-wing, like
where the right-wing online sphere is, okay, with regards to
Israel, it's like crazy to make the
Like, Sagar is totally done with Israel, Tucker is totally done
with it. All these guys are like
borderline just saying the Fuentes rhetoric without any of the
flash to it, without like making, you know, totally crazy statements.
Bro, comparing like the Hassan stuff to the Iranians is wild.
>> morning, the endorsement of a Kurdish civil war campaign.
It really does feel as if things are accelerating
even with the perspectives in modern history of literally 5,
10, even 15 years ago to learn that these are exactly the moves
that we should not be making. And so, I'm really terrified right
now to be saying that our sovereignty itself remains in question
at the behest here of Israel, our very own government, which
seems complicit and is, of course, involved in these very strikes.
And then watching the way that this is all going, I do not see
a single way that this will make the life of any individual American
>> It was, I think, obvious in every TV appearance that
he made. He was never made the case that this was going to help
us in any way. He did make the case that Iran shouldn't have
the bomb, got it. It was never about that, of course. I don't
think he wanted a nuclear Iran. I don't think he likes Iran.
I think he's been told they tried to kill him. I think that's
all real. But, he understood the risks, and it was obvious to
me from talking to him that he didn't want to do this, but that
he kind of couldn't get out of it. And the American >> Dude,
Trump would hate that. Tucker is sitting here like, Trump didn't
want to do it, but I don't know if you guys have been watching
Tucker. Tucker has basically like said Tucker has basically been
saying repeatedly
Trump doesn't want this, but
Israel is going to kill him, just like they killed Kennedy, if
he doesn't do what they want.
Like, yeah, he's pretty That's like the line Tucker's been running
down is Israel is going to murder Trump just like they murdered
Kennedy.
It's very funny. >> president just has less room to maneuver
than voters imagine he does, and it's just a it's a horrible
burden on every on every president since John F. Kennedy. You
can you can feel it, and I think we should all go back and look
at the tapes at pivotal moments, and like these guys just don't
have a latitude they thought they did. And they're bumping up
against immovable objects and pressure that just can't be resisted.
>> Well, it's tragic if that's the case. I will say, I
mean, we can't give it we can't take away the individual action
of our commander-in-chief and of the people who are in power.
And let's be honest here, Tucker, promises were made. You and
I sat in many rooms over the years where we were explicitly told
that this is the one thing that we are going to avoid, war with
Iran. And I do want to make very clear that it's not just about
war with Iran. This is a regime change war with Iran. This is
a regional war with Iran, which is now engulfed our Gulf allies.
This is now a war which is depleting our interceptor stockpile,
calling in the very alliance structure of the United States.
We are potentially pulling interceptors away from South Korea,
which we
>> Dude, I Well, and see, well, I don't necessarily think
that I
>> There is a thing I've been thinking about recently,
which is
Israel sort of entirely tanked their reputation with anybody
below the age of 50 in the United States.
At what point do you not get scared
that Israel will be scared of America?
Like, I And by the way, never get it twisted.
Israel will always put their interests first. Israel The second
you become a threat to Israel in any way, they will take you
out mercilessly.
If they ever think the US are a threat and they can do something
to neutralize that threat, they will do it instantly.
And so, I'm like, they're totally nuking their reputation with
like everybody in the West. Everybody hates Israel at this point.
Like, everybody under 50 seems to really despise Israel or let's
say 70%. It's like 70/30.
I wonder if they start to get concerned that that reputation's
going that way. It's uh it's very concerning. >> do 400%
more trade with >> You and Vaush are on like the exact
same page? Well, I'm not No, I'm not on the same page with Vaush.
Vaush is crazy,
Well, I do enjoy watching Vaush sometimes to hear him talk about
Israel. Vaush is [__] crazy. Vaush is way out further
than I am, okay?
Vaush is Okay, get the [__] out of here you're going
to compare me with And I I don't say that as in I I hate Vaush,
but Vaush is like Vaush has been going
sicko mode on Israel. He's been saying crazy [__]
okay?
Uh anyway, stop slandering the Nostradamus of the left. Vaush
is usually right. That's the other scary thing. Vaush is usually
right.
Vaush hates the UAE?
Based. Everyone should hate the UAE.
>> with then Israel. I mean, take the combined GCC bilateral
trade, the Gulf Arab nations with the United States compared
to Israel, and you have Gulf officials who are furious going
on national television saying that they are being deprioritized.
Their very ministers at this moment you and I are speaking are
talking about withdrawing their economic investments in our companies.
Trillions of dollars at stake. And all of that belies the very
people who I think he talked about, the American soldier. And
I've been thinking all week about Declan Cody. He was 20 years
old and he perished in that attack in on our base in Kuwait.
He was born four to five years after 9/11. I'm literally in this
business to try and to make sure to make that that something
like that doesn't happen. It breaks me to watch somebody who
was just that young, who had their entire life ahead of them
perish in another Middle Eastern war. Not to mention including
one of the servicemen who was a mother of children. She had you
know, had hobbies. She had a husband. And I I have to say, you
know, you know, I I cannot let our individual leaders off the
hook here. Secretary Hagseth recently made a statement at the
Pentagon podium where he said and chastised the national media
for not celebrating more of the quote wins that were happening
in Iran and spending too much time on the dead American soldiers
trying to Why he looks like Kash
You are just racist. What the [__] He looks nothing
like Kash
he's saying.
That's crazy racism right there. >> to highlight that as
if it's some sort of political prop. And part of the reason I'm
here today, and part of the reason I do my show every day, is
just to say it's not 2003. I will not be blackmailed, silenced,
or told that we cannot mourn our dead, that we cannot support
our troops without supporting the war. This is over. We are absolutely
declaring an end to this. I thought, I think you thought, many
others thought that this was an end whenever it came to the Trump
election in 2024, and it is a tragic actually to have to be able
to sit here and talk to you about the situation today. >> I
mean, the the the vote for Trump, which I cast, and I try not
to vote I don't vote that much to be totally honest with you.
Never have, because I'm always traveling. But I I voted
That's so stupid. How are you a political analyst for as long
as you are? I don't I don't really vote cuz like I'm always tra
What?
That's a terrible excuse.
What the [__] >> for absentee for Trump. >> Bro,
you're rich as [__] too. You could easily just get
like an assistant to fill out an absentee ballot for you. You
just request it. Get it filled out. So stupid. >> And I'm
was happy to do it, and I think a lot of people who don't normally
vote did the same. And they did it in part as a vote for
That's what we're That's the debate. Is does the United States
have a right to make decisions in its own interest and the interest
of its own people? Does your vote actually matter?
Are you voting for BB every time whether you want to or not?
Are you actually voting for an American who might help your country?
And I think we kind of answered that question. Like there's If
if Trump isn't going to save us from a system that kind of hates
us, then what's the option? >> Right? And I you look, I
mean, I'm pleading. I know that many people in the administration
are going to listen.
>> Why? Why did Trump betray us? It's almost like Trump
hasn't kept his word. It's almost like Trump has been lying to
us.
Can you imagine that?
What does that say about our country?
Uh sorry, I'm trying to do something >> me just lay out
the case already the damage that on the United States. Our alliance
structure in the Gulf Arab nations is in question. We have multiple
bases which have been hit. These are allies which pump billions
of dollars into our economy. Their very lifeblood is at threat
right now. Force majeure been declared. Qatar LNG production
has significantly declined. The very morning that you and I are
taping this, we just got a very >> Uh Kuwait just did the
same thing.
we've got at least two of the Gulf states right now who are basically
like, "Hey, we can't pull oil out of the ground anymore. We don't
have anywhere to put it. Can't go through the Strait of Hormuz.
We're fucked." >> Very troubling jobs report, 92,000 losses
in the economy. We actually saw unemployment tick up for native-born
Americans. That is the very opposite of what Donald Trump wanted
on the campaign trail. An oil analyst that I deeply respect,
I spoke to him this morning. If the Strait of Hormuz remain closed,
he projects oil at $200 per barrel. This is a disaster, a full-fledged
disaster. The very day you and I are speaking, again, gas prices
are at the highest price in Donald Trump's entire presidency
now so far. So, you can see very clearly for the individual pocketbooks
of every American, they will feel the results of this war. And
then, geopolitically, when you say sovereignty, what is that
about? Sovereignty, the questioning of NATO which Trump and many
of his officials talked about. It's not about subsuming our national
interest in transnational organizations. But even then, we are
watching. If you care so much about NATO, I've been trying to
make this point to the neocons, the Ukrainians are already noticing
that many of the weapon systems which would be needed to defend
them if they wanted to continue this war are going to be depleted
and they're not very high on the priority list. I talked about
South Korea, about Japan, about our our actual economic commits
to real allies, by the way, people who we do a lot of trade with,
who love us and we love them. Watch how we are abandoning them.
If you care about China and trying to project power in the South
China Sea, the interceptor stockpile that we are using right
now is a joke compared to what some potential conflict with Taiwan
would look like. We're already slow >> Dude, it's uh
>> Uh the the sad thing is is every other power on the
planet like so I I say every other power China and Russia are
like so psyched about this and they're going to tip the scales
in any way they can into Iran's favor, right? They're just going
to keep trying as hard as they possibly can just to do little
things to just kind of tip into Iran's favor. You say good Nemo,
but it's not good. It's not good because the United States is
kind of [__] right now and
everything they lose they have a hard time replacing. They are
the most They are the most impressive military in the world,
but the problem is is they're they're bombing a country that's
not a threat to them and they're going to make the actual threats
to them like capable of doing things as a result. It's
it's like kind of terrifying, right?
it's rough. Now hopefully domestic production of military like
basically ordinance and all of this [__] can increase
massively and it won't be that big a deal, but man it looks spooky
right now. >> We are removing many of those options off
the table. We are not stronger as a result of this action and
I do not see an off-ramp currently floated by the president of
the United States who is now declaring unconditional surrender.
Tucker, you and I we've bonded often over history. Let's remember
unconditional surrender and what it takes. It takes
>> Dude, Tucker goes on a rant here a rant and it's epic.
>> urban conflict and invasion of Europe in the battle
of Berlin. It takes dropping atomic bombs in Japan, floating
hundreds of thousands of American casualties if we needed to
invade Japan to occupy and demand that very policy. It takes
Ulysses S. Grant who is willing to
literally hundreds of thousands of casualties for an entire year-long
period to get to that point. That's what unconditional surrender
means and that is what the president has been demanding and I
want every American to realize that. Unconditional surrender
that is the true demand and it is now. He said, "President Trump
said make Iran great again." Uh this morning. That is and only
be enforced with a ocean of American blood, and that is not something
in our national interest. We are walking every single day closer
to that possibility, and it is an abomination, if you ask me.
>> Unconditional surrender means foreign troops get to
rape your wife and daughter. Everyone can feel. [laughter] >> I
mean, kind of true. Kind of possibly true, but like I just love
that he's like, "That's why they will never unconditionally surrender,
cuz it means that Americans get to come in and [__]
your wife." And it's like I don't think America can do that anymore.
I That used to be what unconditional surrender meant, but it's
not really like you don't go and sack cities as the like global
hegemon. That's not okay. All right? Now, Americans did do a
lot of that, I believe, in Vietnam, but that wasn't like unconditional
surrender. That was like a war that was happening and them going
over like That could still happen, if you had like soldiers running
into civilian villages and stuff. Unconditional surrender would
mean American troops pulling out. >> That That's like the
most atavistic instinct there is. And so, to avoid that, people
will do anything. And so, that's why it requires that level of
force to get a population subdued to the point of unconditional
surrender. That's why. And so, in this case, of course, we don't
have the ground force necessary. I don't think Americans would
voluntarily participate in it. I just don't think we can do that.
It would require weapons of mass destruction. It would require,
presumably, nuclear weapons in order to do that.
>> I I watched a Fuentes clip of him talking about how
Trump I I thought I was going to be totally on board with what
Fuentes was saying, but then Fuentes was all like, "I don't know
Trump really understands that it would be a lot of human life."
And I don't think I don't think Trump gives a [__]
about that. I think Trump wants to be the guy who fired off one
of the big nukes, who went like ham.
I think I think there's a chance that Trump just wants to like
nuke some [__] Just for the sake of it. Just to be
like, "I'm the guy who nuked."
And honestly, for no other reason. Not really strategic reasons,
almost nothing. Just to be like, "Yeah, I'm the guy that did
it. I'm the guy who I nuked
>> And let's not let's not lie to ourselves. We're moving
toward that.
>> Yes, and that is another important point that I think
you have been highlighting here. Is if you look at the decision
matrix where everything is about upping the ante. A good friend
of mine actually pointed out so many of the Vietnam aspects that
were already starting to climb. So you watch very quickly. We
thought we could just decapitate the Ayatollah and they would
crawl over and make a deal. It didn't happen. So then what happens?
We have to start bombing the police stations, the border guards
to be able to make sure that these core Kurdish CIA-backed groups
can make an incursion, that they can start their civil war in
part of the country, distract the security force. At every step
when the Iranians reject an American overture, the natural if
choice of the American president will be escalation and bombing.
Already, I mean, watching statements coming out of the Pentagon,
it's shocking. It's like military assistance command Tehran.
They're bragging, I mean, Tucker, as a again as an American who
really was radicalized by the Iraq war, to see the chairman of
the joint chairman of the joint chiefs of staff about how we've
already to drop double the munitions of shock and awe. I actually
felt like I was going insane because we have learned nothing.
Already they're talking about we have uh struck 2,000 different
targets across the country. Look, you don't have to believe me,
go and look at footage from the ground. It doesn't look like
civil war has erupted, civil society, or any of that. The Iranian
regime remains relatively in power as of right now. And so when
you again up the ante, which President Trump did with his demand
for unconditional surrender, remember they told us it was just
about nuclear weapons, then it was about ballistic missiles,
then it was about projecting terrorism or something in the region,
which is you know, nebulous and undefinable. It's designed for
that reason by the way, so that we would have to be able to go
to war. Well, then we now get to unconditional surrender, which
is orally enforceable with massive weapons, nuclear weapons in
this case. And now we have two nuclear armed powers, Israel and
the United States, which are engaged in this conflict. And the
Israeli part of this equation is really important. America actually
does have an interest in a stable Iran because of the Straits
of Hormuz, which by the way, our empire is now having to insure
oil tankers moving through the Straits of Hormuz and potentially
put all of our navy sailors at risk to escort ships through.
Does it even >> Bro, Megyn Kelly's completely red-pilled.
Dude, Megyn Kelly's been going off. And Ben Shapiro Ben Shapiro's
having to watch all of his friends like turn to hating Israel.
What did Megyn Kelly say? Hold on, what is this? Want to suggest
that pro-Israel voices stop going on Piers Morgan even though
it's good for likes. That'll make it harder for him to make money
platforming freaks like Ana Kasparian, Cenk Uygur, and the real
Candace Owens. All these clowns were cheering me on when I supported
Israel's right to defend itself and asked pro-Palestinian guests
if they condemn Hamas.
But from the moment I started criticizing the Israeli government's
excessive response, they branded me anti-Semitic and tried to
cancel me. It's a coordinated playbook and it's
It's Yeah, I I'm sorry. I'm like I'm on the same page.
Unfortunately, like at this point, man,
I don't know how to say this in a way that doesn't make me sound
totally insane, totally crazy.
Like I I don't see the other people I don't see
I don't see the downsides of like the Iran stuff. Like I don't
It's not a part of my daily life. I just see what happens with
the uh like the consequences of like people reacting to Israel's
actions and I just see Israel's like the
the problem.
I'm sorry. I see you guys as the
I see you guys as the problem. I don't know what else to say,
man. You seem like the problem.
I don't Uh not a bot here. Lion of Zion. Not a bot here. What
happened to you, Kelly? Can you no longer tell right from wrong,
good from evil, justice from injustice? I know hatred is popular,
but Kever never thought you would fall into that.
>> Dude, it's rough, man. It's rough.
>> Didn't happen to you. Did you know that almost 80% of
the oil moving through the Strait of Hormuz goes to Asia? 50%
of it goes to China. So, we're ensuring and paying for Chinese
oil for the Strait of Hormuz. But Israel doesn't care about any
of that. There's There's a quote from an Israeli analyst in the
Financial Times who said, "Look, if they change the regime, great.
If they have a civil war, great. If anything happens, great."
I'm imagining that the reason you have to go
and allow oil to go to China is so that like the cost of manufacturing
goods in China doesn't matter and especially Asia. You need oil
in Asia so you can have fuel in Asia so that you can do the shipping
around India, Asia, um all of the the Indo-Pacific,
right? Because there's tons of different countries who have super
integrated supply chains around there. And if oil is expensive,
you're going to have all of those countries, like the the cost
of shipping goods, of making goods, will go up massively. And
that does have downstream effects in America. So, it's probably
why they're going to allow all that oil to go through because
Trump doesn't want, you know, 10, 20, 30% inflation.
Otherwise, he's even more. Although, who knows who knows if he
even cares at this >> as they can no longer pose a regional
threat to the nation of Israel, then the Israelis are happy.
We have divergent interests, actually, in what happens in the
country of Iran. But, this president has fused them with Bibi
Netanyahu. And by doing that, he has sold us, truly, into Pandora's
Box. And now, even extricating from this situation, if the president
just declared victory today, which by the way, Mr. President,
please do so. It will be the best thing, smartest decision you
have ever made in your entire presidency. Unfortunately, I don't
think that's going to happen. Even if he did, think about all
the fundamental questions of US alliances that were already in
the minds of these Gulf leaders, of Japan, of South Korea, of
Taiwan, any potential US ally around the globe. Hundreds of billions
have already basically been put to the test. The war is costing,
internal Pentagon projection, $1 billion per day every single
time that this goes on. And extraordinary measures are already
being taken. I just read this morning, the Russians are providing
intelligence to the Iranians to help them target US bases. Not
like we can complain, can we? That That's how the Pentagon runs
the entire Ukraine war. As we learned from the Discord leaks,
we do their battle damage assessments, we give them the coordinates,
and we tell them exactly where to shoot. So, we are entangled
in a deep conflict which has immense risk for the global energy
markets, for our own soldiers, for the region. We talked also
about sovereignty. Let's talk about the refugee crisis. My favorite
question that you told asked Ted Cruz, he didn't even know the
population of Iran. 92 million, by the way. 92 million, 1/3 almost
the size of the United States of America. Destabilize a country
which if we give them the Gaza treatment, which again looks currently
potentially likely, and especially when the Israeli >> Let's
see now. He's going to mention Yair Lapid.
No, no, no, no, no. It wasn't Lapid. It wasn't Lapid. Did I show
this on stream? It was uh Oh, it's not Bank of Years, the other
guy, Smotrich. Smotrich was like, we're going to make I think
he said we're going to make Beirut look like we're going to give
them we're going to make it look like Khan Yunis, right? Make
Beirut or Lebanon look like Khan Yunis. No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no. This wasn't Bennett. I could have sworn it was um
Or maybe they both said it. I I know I saw a quote from Smotrich
saying it.
>> are involved. What does that mean? Mass >> Khan
Yunis being the one of the bigger prettier cities in Gaza. So,
as in we're going to flatten this entire city. It's crazy, man.
>> Mass immiseration, mass refugee flow
>> Dahiyeh will resemble Khan Yunis. Smotrich warns of
Gaza-like destruction coming to Lebanon. Yeah, that's what it
>> all across Middle East, across Europe. Turkey is already
I mean, you have Naftali Bennett, the former Israeli Prime Minister,
already saying, "Oh, actually Turkey is already now a threat
to Israel." I A friend of mine predicted the dissolution of NATO
will not come from America. It will come from an Israeli action
on Turkey. And I hate to say it, it looks even more likely today.
Turkey, again, actually a good ally. We have a good base there.
We have a decades-long relationship. All of that apparently is
being thrown out as long as it's in Israel's national security
>> So, if you game us out a little bit, what that means
>> By the way, this guy is like
This guy was not like a crazy conservative, just so you know.
Like I I I think this guy was pretty middle of the road when
he started his show with Krystal like 2 years ago. This guy was
not like out of his mind.
This whole thing is driving people. If you just want to know
where this is driving people, man.
No way we would do this in Turkey? No, no, no, no, no. He's saying
that what He's saying that somebody told him and he agrees with
it now that the reason they would dissolve NATO is because they
didn't want to invoke Article 5 on an Israeli action on
>> It's because countries under threat flee to safety.
>> Honestly, oh, is he He's 5 years with Krystal now? Okay.
>> If they do like people do, if our allies in the Gulf,
which are real allies, actually, like we get to as you just said,
we get massive benefit from our alliances with these countries.
>> Dude, talk about the Turkey thing. >> But if they
feel unprotected by the United States, and I it seems like they
do, cuz they are, they're going to go somewhere else. That's
It's same for Turkey. So, I'm not for NATO because I don't think
it's fully under US
>> Can Israel join NATO? >> Israel's got some special
designation that makes them basically equal to NATO in the eyes
of the United States.
But nobody's saying like Turkey is in NATO. The whole thing they're
saying here is that Israel Israel obviously sees Turkey as a
threat. Turkey is the only country that can compete with them
in the Mediterranean like as the hegemon of that region. They
will eventually hit Turkey. I whether they're going to hit them
through espionage, through cyber attacks, through what it's >> hot
difficult to be said.
>> Like we we we don't really know. Also, I think Turkey
might be able to veto them joining NATO, no? Wouldn't Turkey
be able to veto that? Oh, they can't join NATO because they have
contested territories. I see.
They already tried to do coup Turkey. Yeah, it's they hate Turkey
though. Turkey is like their big
Turkey is their next Iran to quote Naftali Bennett. >> on
the other hand, the option is powerful states, emerging states
like Turkey, which is not getting less powerful with time, will
align with the BRICS, of course. And so So, the net effect of
this >> German Gunder, thank you for the What is that?
14 months, thank you so much for upping your for re-upping your
sub. I appreciate it, man. >> the United States to get
us to pull out of the Middle East, which Israel wants, and to
weaken the Gulf states, and to destroy Europe, which Israel hates
for some reason. It's always hated Europe. So, I mean, maybe
there are obvious reasons. I don't know, but they they have embedded
the decline of Europe very aggressively. Now, you're seeing Iranian
refugees massing in France to cross the English Channel, this
is this morning, to Great Britain. So, it's already happening.
The migrant flow is already going into Europe. Like, tell me
that wasn't the point from the start. Of course, it was. >> Exactly.
And this is the this And this is why I find it so galling to
actually have this adminis- Sorry. You won't I I hate to say
it. I hate to say it, okay?
Nobody will be anywhere near as mad about Persians going I'm
sorry. It's like a it will not be the same. It just won't be
the same. >> be the ones who are perpetuating this policy.
We understood that the global effects of this refugee crisis
inspired, you know, things like Brexit, things like declarations
of sovereignty, the Donald Trump election in 2016.
This was genuinely a rejection of that. And then to watch the
Syria-Libya playbook currently being played out. I mean, you
know, unfortunately, I find many people know Syria and Libya
were disasters, but they can't eventually explain why. So, let's
take some time. What was it? There was a so-called protest, you
know, against Bashar al-Assad. That protest movement quickly
became subsumed by radical jihadists. The United States, for
no reason, basically decided that it was in our interest to remove
Bashar al-Assad, massively fund all of these jihadists in the
region, gave them weapons, gave them time, money, support, of
course. And what happened? It created a gigantic civil war, as
you always talk about, it destroyed the Christian community,
some of the less radical elements of that society. >> Dude,
dude, when you really think about dude, Iran is like
triple the size of my country in terms of population.
Like, I can't imagine like being of my country being like totally
destabilized, like multiple groups of forces like all all engaging
in civil war. And then it's a country triple the size.
That's going to be like massively
It's actually wild when you think like
it's crazy.
Uh it's >> And now 14 years later, a literal Al-Qaeda terrorist
is their president. The only reason that we don't talk about
him that way is cuz he's a friend of Israel and allowed portions
of his country to basically be annexed by them. That's what >> I
think this is wrong by the way. I
From what I what I recall, it's HTS was the militia he was leading,
right? That was a Turkish-backed militia, right?
I do not I think Sager's up here. I do not think this guy is
like a friend of Israel. I do think he's more of a or maybe this
is my cope if like maybe there is some kind of deep state and
maybe they are like trying to undercut Israel in some ways where
like it was a Turkish-US-backed
militia that went in and finally, you know, dealt the death blow
to Assad and took over. And that there's there's that little
militia and then the US wants their leader that like somebody
favor somebody favorable to them to be installed in Iran, not
somebody favorable to Israel. And maybe they're like trying to
offset some things in that region a little bit. I don't know.
But it's man, that's total I feel like
I feel like I hope I just hope that, but I it's probably it's
almost certainly just cope. >> Israelis want? They want
and they had no problem with seeing an a rump state emerge in
Iran, but that's not in our interest. That's not in Europe's
interest, that's not in our allies' interest. It is massively
destabilizing. Same in Libya. The what was the promise? No-fly
zone for Gaddafi. He unfortunately he literally gets on national
television on a video which, you know, deeply inspired Kim Jong-un
and many other uh regimes that wanted to race to a nuclear weapon.
I've been told directly that whenever we asked the United uh
when we asked >> Why does Tucker smile like a total psycho
when he says
What the [__] >> Same in Libya. The what was
the promise? No flies known for Gaddafi. He unfortunately He
literally gets on national television on a video, which, you
know, deeply inspired Kim Jong Un and many other uh regimes that
wanted to race
>> It Tucker Tucker is a part of the CIA, so he's just
like
"If only you knew what really happened there." Or something.
I don't know. >> race to a nuclear weapon. I've been told
directly that whenever we asked the United uh when we asked in
those bilateral meetings with Kim Jong Un, we said "Why don't
you just give up your nuclear weapon?" He said "Look at what
happened to Gaddafi." He's never going to do it. And he shouldn't.
In fact, his his entire policy has been vindicated. So, that's
another element of this. Let's think about nuclear proliferation.
Since the outbreak of the Iran war, Poland has now declared their
intent to try to become a nuclear power, a nuclear armed state.
France said they were going to increase the amount of nuclear
weapons that they have under >> I mean, this is just This
is just facts.
Like, it literally is you do need nuclear weapons.
Like, nuclear nonproliferation is dead.
And you almost wonder if like that could be another reason Trump
is going to try to fire a nuclear weapon.
Like, nonproliferation is totally dead. It's over.
>> their production and they are no longer going to publicize
them. South Korea and Japan are going to be having some very
serious discussions around this. So, in an ostensible war over
a nuclear program, we've actually probably inspired more nuclear
proliferation than even the war in Iraq, which I did not think
was ever possible. So, to watch this all continue in the spiral,
none of it works to our benefit. And you and I are not NATO defenders.
You know, we've talked often about uh We talked often about the
folly of expanding NATO eastward. However, we can recognize we
have fundamental interests in a few select group countries. The
problem with NATO is it got far away from our core security interest.
But now countries in the core security umbrella themselves are
questioning their fundamental relationship with the United States.
You know, the Eastern Baltic region is not one that keeps me
up at night. But Japan, South Korea, uh you know, Japan and South
Korea, the G >> I've not heard a lot from Japan and South
Korea. But like
it does make sense that the US is really overextending in the
Middle East. They keep pulling aircraft carriers here into the
Middle East. It's like
aren't aren't Japan and South Korea and like that whole island
chain, aren't those like way more critical to US
prosperity than anything in the Middle
Like technically the US has all the oil it needs for itself.
Between the US, Canada, Venezuela, like this whole Central American
like Mon- Monroe Doctrine sphere, all of these countries there's
everything that you need here, right? You don't need to secure
that stuff in the Middle East. It's good to have it be stable.
But, it's not it's not required.
and realistically like Iran was not destabilizing the region
to the extent that this had to happen with the lack total lack
of planning with which it did, okay?
No, because Jesus isn't coming back in Japan, idiot. Well, like
that's honestly like what else is it? Cuz there's no strategic
benefit to doing
makes up for all the costs. It There just isn't. There's nothing.
And I don't So, to me it has to be like the religious thing.
It has to be the just the total kooks, man. And or whoever's
influenced enough by like AIPAC and and Israel in general. It
is key that our currency be the currency the rest of the world
trades oil in. So, I hear this all the time. I probably need
to go watch some somebody talk about the petrodollar and why
this is all important. Cuz I understand that it's important that
people buy and sell barrels of oil with US dollars. I understand
that. Um something along the lines of like this is important
for making sure people buy US debt.
I I kind of get it. Somebody like I think Marty Epstein's trying
to explain it to me a little bit before, but I don't know if
that has to do with the petrodollar or not.
Anyway, we keep going. >> GCC countries which Look, you
know, I'm not saying we need a massive bases or any of that in
the re- >> Well, it's something to do with like as long
as it's as long as people trade in US dollars, then they'll want
to buy treasury bonds or something. And then because you buy
treasury bonds, blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah, eventually
US gets to like
take out debt and never produce anything and have a totally like
made up country and economy.
Yeah, that's that's my understanding of it, okay? I should I
should know more. >> reason, but we need oil, we need natural
gas to keep flowing nicely. We need some of that money to be
coming back here. And that's obviously very beneficial to our
companies. Those things being called into question erodes the
foundation of the American empire, which actually does serve
the United States. So, what we're watching is like the far-flung
parts, which always break an empire's back, actually call into
question the security core commitments, our national security
commitments at a very base level, which is very, very weakening
to the United >> People seem to be more inflamed, not just
emotionally, but physi >> it cover for all kinds of other
things. So, you don't find out for like >> Hold on, hold
on. Back it up. Back it >> Notice because chaos is in part
used to, and it always is a cover for all kinds of other things
that you don't find out for like 3 years later. You know, like
2 days after 9/11 something dramatic happened you never heard
about it. Um right, so bad people become more powerful in chaos
and they do bad things and you don't even notice. But, one of
the bad things that's happening is Israel is taking over Southern
Lebanon.
And uh you know, more aggressively oppressing the West Bank and
making >> Dude, I just thought it's like crazy when you
look at Lebanon
and like they're moving to Beirut. When I see like the the strike
on the This is what always gets me about when Israel does stuff.
It's like dude, I've not seen this [__] from the
US. I saw some apartment building get struck in Lebanon and the
whole condo unit comes down. And I'm just like, bro, I I don't
see that from US strikes. I'm sure it happens
But, like it just seems like I never see that from the US in
the way I see it from Israel uh both in Gaza and now in Lebanon.
Like
it's crazy.
>> Was in Syria what how can Israel spare the military
capacity the men's and armament in the middle of this massive
war with Iran to take over southern Lebanon and why are we allowing
that? >> Yeah, that's a great question. Who do you think
sells them the weapons and staffs their intelligence and basically
supports their entire nation state and military? It's us and
that's the reason. They could never have struck Tehran like this
on their own by their own admission. That's why they all Speaking
of 1 hour ago, Lebanon's death toll nears 400 with at least four
killed by Israeli strike on Beirut hotel. They struck the Ramada
hotel.
WHY YOU STRIKE THE RAMADA? What the
It's a hotel by definition people who don't live there.
Maybe it was like a tight
It was like a tight strike. Maybe it was one of those ones that
just blows up the apartment only.
Should we just say
This is just what the whole Middle East gets to look like now.
By the way, no possible way you actually like kill off all of
the radical people, you just make way more.
Dude, I
Oh dude, I saw some footage from Lebanon Skyline, too. I think
this gets crazy, doesn't it? I thought there was like crazy stuff
of like you actually get to see mass explosions in the skyline
there. Maybe
Whatever. Always whatever the United States This is fine. This
is fine. This is fine. For once would say the most honest thing
of his entire life. It's been my dream to go after Iran for 40
years. 40 years it's been a dream. And so called you have Republican
senators on our national television with no shame saying that
Iran has been an imminent threat to the United States for 40
years. I think they need to go back to school and read the definition
of imminent. But at the very least this propaganda is completely
unchecked by our press. It is just accepted. It is currently
the party line. But let's get to it. You know what you just talked
about there with Lebanon. Again, if you don't read the Israeli
press which in some cases is actually more honest than our own
press, ironically. >> Much more. >> There's a quote
where they say that >> That's the crazy thing. That's the
craziest thing to me is he'll be like, "Dude, Israel wants to
take over like the whole Middle East. They like they want all
these people destroyed. They want them destabilized." And people
be like, "You're an anti-Semite. Why would you say Israel's like
conspiring to do this?" I was like,
Look at any of their statements in the press. Look at the leaders
of their parties. Look at It's all in public. They just say it.
They just say it. I'm not anti-Semitic for reading. I'm not anti-Semitic
That can't be That can't be a thing. You can't call me anti-Semitic
cuz I read what they said. That's not true. You can't You can't
make me think it. You can't make me believe it. >> Really
minister said, "We will turn Dahieh into Gaza." That's basically
what he said. "We are going to take an area of Beirut and we
are going to level it to the ground." That's what he said. That
is an open admission from the Israeli ministers. What you can
see already with the belligerence in all of these different countries
from the strikes in Doha to Syria >> Dude, that actually
should be a thing. Hold on. It's like this clicking this button,
it's actually an anti-Semitic act to click this button, okay?
is fine. If you click this button, it turns it into an anti-Semitic
message, okay? Nobody in Israel would ever say this. Israel must
destroy all of Iran's oil fields and energy energy industry on
Kharg Island, causing like even more chaos in that country, okay?
This is what will [__] Iran's economy and topple
the regime.
Need to destroy all their nuclear nuclear facilities, all of
the ballistic missile industry, and Hezbollah in Lebanon. It
all needs to be destroyed,
>> Generic user, "Oh, cool, an Israeli. What is he saying?
I support the killing of subhuman Palestinians, especially women
and children." I'm trying to say Okay, it's not quite that bad,
but it's a Listen,
I wish I wish it was further from the truth, okay? I just I wish
I I
I wish it was further from the truth. That's all. >> Uh
now to Lebanon, is this is about regional hegemony for the state
of Israel? I also think that their political popularity dramatically
declining in the United States at this time makes it more existential
for them than ever. They know that this is literally their last
chance to knock off any individual power which dares try to either
host different types of groups or have a government which may
>> I'll be real, okay?
personally on purely
purely like history nerd
video game grounds hated Turkey, okay?
Because obviously
is every white nerd's dream to retake Constantinople, okay? Just
a fact. Just a fact, but I've always hated Turkey. But honestly,
this this like action against Iran
I like I I might love Turkey now. I might be pro Erdogan. I'm
not joking. I'm not joking. I might be per This is the first
spite-based position I've really taken in politics, okay? I just
love Erdogan now. I love Erdogan. I love Turkey. I I KNOW, it's
terrible. He's like a terrible
brutal strongman leader. Yep. But it's purely on like those grounds
that I'm just like, "Oh, I hope Turkey wins. I really hope Turkey
wins." >> may check them in some way. And that's part of
why our president's decision to join them is so disappointing
because you can see very clearly. And you know, I I I think you
said >> You mean Byzantium? I do mean Byzantium.
Wait, no, no, no, Constantinople. No, it was Byzantium, it's
Constantinople,
>> This I often used to. I get it from Israel's perspective.
But I'm not Israeli. But I'm not Israeli. My job, our job is
to look out for our country. And so to see the vast armaments
of the United States of America effectively prop up Israeli regional
hegemony at the direct expense of our own power projection is
shocking. So watch very closely what's going to happen with Lebanon.
You're going to see the mass expansion very likely because of
Hezbollah rockets and ballistic missiles which have been shot
into Israel. That will be the pretext for a full-scale, you know,
rid up basically reduction campaign. That's what they like to
call it. You're going to see very similar actions right now in
Gaza and in the West Bank. Don't forget, I know you haven't seen
this, or I know you've seen this. An American citizen was killed
in the West Bank very very recently. Not that anybody in America
cares at all. He's from Philadelphia, by the way, and his own
senator won't even stand up for him, Senator John Fetterman,
a Democrat. Just to show you some of the bipartisanship of this
nature. That's why it's sickening to watch. I mean, we've we've
described this before. It's not a healthy relationship. We're
so far beyond that. We need to wake up and we need to reclaim
our sovereignty right now. And this has nothing to do with anti-Semitism.
We can I mean, I I just laid out the very strategic case for
why
>> Yeah, guys, Byzantium was the name before it was Constantinople.
Same city.
Same city. >> Individualism can hurt you in the immediate
short-term and your pocketbook in the long-term from our geopolitical
allies, our strategic situation in the region, and then across
the globe. If you care about China, chips, anything, really.
You're watching the degradation of our ability to project force.
And that is not only shocking, but it is a >> New intro?
What?
No. No.
>> Istanbul was Constantinople now. >> No. No. Not
Not are we using that song.
Too much pain in that song. >> Origins Christ. >> Too much
pain in that song. Which unfortunately again, you are not going
to hear much of this from our mainstream media networks, which
are just cheering on this war, bringing on, you know, Iranian
diaspora. Tucker, a a friend of mine made this joke. He said,
"America's only country in the world where immigrants come here
to try and get us to bomb their home country and their family."
And you know >> what's the sickness of that relationship?
Because I think you know this as well. I'll say it here. I'm
technically part of the Indian diaspora. My parents are from
there. I'm from Bryan, Texas. Never ask me what's going on in
India, please. I don't know anything. I'm not from there. I don't
know anything about it. Uh I barely know what's going on in my
own home country. You know, it's it'll be actually be disgraceful
for me to try and to speak on behalf of them. Let them speak
for themselves. And I I I can't get over watching the BBC recently
had a package where they had on three individuals Iranian who
were celebrating the bombing of their home country. And my friend
Trisha Parसी was like, "I'm sorry, this is sickening." Like look,
maybe that's one perspective, but that's not the only perspective.
In fact, it might be a minority perspective from what we see
currently what's happening on the ground in the country. So,
let's not deny
>> Dude, going through some of those crazy pictures of
like oil raining down from the sky in Tehran.
I'm just sitting there like
Do you think where the monarchists? Are they still like this
is awesome?
when Pete Hegseth goes the only people who should be worried
are Iranians who think they're going to live.
Hey guys, are you hoping are you still thinking that this government
wants to liberate your people? You think that's a priority for
them? The only people who should be concerned are the Iranians
who think they're going to live. It's like bro. [laughter] They're
going to nuke Tehran. They're like going to straight up nuke
Tehran, >> I the people of Iran their agency >> Wait,
I assume that's hyperbole? Me talking about Pete Hegseth? No,
that's not hyperbole. Pete Hegseth said that literally verbatim.
It's not good. >> Since allegedly we're supposed to care
about that and their protest movements, let's recognize this
is a highly heterogeneous this is a massive heterogeneous country
with a lot of disparate types of opinions and we can look to
history to say that when we demand unconditional surrender, again,
I'm sure you've seen the literature on this. What did the unconditional
surrender demands do? demand do? to the German populace even
when the Nazi party was massively underwater in terms of its
popularity. They said, "We have no choice. We must fight to the
death." >> That's what they declared. The Japanese I mean
there was a lot of consternation in their society about the way
that the war was going. Once you fire bomb Tokyo and you kill
100,000 people in a single night and you say that that unconditional
surrender and the removal of your emperor is the only thing that
we're going to accept, well, a lot more of those people died
over the you know, the next several months. And so, we're probably
going to watch that happen now with Iran. It's the same dynamic
that always plays out. >> And the point, of course, is
to build Israeli empire to replace American empire, which is
dying, hastened by this war with Israeli empire. And one thing
I noticed, I can't contain myself and have to express it, but
when you say that the Israelis are destroying Beirut, which is,
having been to a lot of places in the world, one of the prettiest
places on the globe, Beirut is just is a marvel, it's beautiful.
It reminds me, um, and being destroyed by Israel, which is one
of the single ugliest countries in the world. Nothing of beauty
has been built there since 1948, sorry. I've been everywhere
in that country and it's true. Is it the nature of this emerging
empire is destructive, and it always seems like beautiful things
will >> Dude, Tucker is going crazy. This
This sent people into like conniptions on Twitter, unironically.
Like people are so, so, so angry about that quote
People are so [__] mad about that quote specifically.
That's not true, right?
Well, what do you mean that's not true?
I'm Like, okay, it's not true as in I I doubt
they have a serious tech sector.
Wait, what? What does that have to do? You could Bro, I'm sure
some tech sectors in San Francisco look like [__]
But it's Was that not He's saying nothing of beauty has been
created there. Like nothing of beauty has been built there. He's
saying like he doesn't like their architecture, he doesn't like
their city planning, he doesn't like the way they just their
aesthetic design of anything. Says it's an ugly place.
I didn't I didn't >> wind up being destroyed. Europe? Right?
>> Wait, what does he mean? How did Israel destroy Europe?
Is it the nature of this emerging empire is destructive, and
it always seems like beautiful things wind up being destroyed.
Europe? Right?
>> By the way, the way Israel destroyed Europe was causing
the Syrian Civil War and causing like Arab Arab Muslim refugees
to flee to Europe, okay? That was the way That In Tucker's mind,
that's how they destroyed
Which like I start to get, you know, that's bordering on it's
a little rough when you say that.
parts of Syria, the holy sites. I I don't know parts of Iran
are apparently beautiful, totally blown up. This does seem like
a war on beauty as well, which next to truth is like this is
not an American perspective, but it's a Christian perspective
and real perspective. It's a global perspective. Beauty is worth
And yet it seems the determined effort of the IDF to destroy
beauty. And I just want to say that because I really notice >> I
mean we watched some of that in Gaza and you don't have to be
a Hamas lover to recognize the beauty of some of those churches
or of the society of the West Bank, which I'm sure that you have
seen as well. And yeah, I've been and spent some a lot of my
life in a large portion of this region. I mean I'm watching my
former neighborhood in Doha, Qatar with missiles flying down.
And by the way, uh I think it was exactly a mile from where I
used to live when I was in high school uh in Doha, Qatar that
the Israelis actually struck that Hamas compound and actually
even killed a Qatari police officer. I can't imagine what's on
my, you know, Look, this could have been me. You know, once upon
a time I was in a classmate at the American School of Doha. It's
March. Uh so it's just school time. There are children, American
children by the way, you know, children of oil executives, others.
I was my children child child of professors of many American
universities which operate there who are now in a panic mode
trying to get out of the country. >> Who the [__]
asked cigar? >> As their airports are There are a million
plus Americans who live in the region and it has been very short
the evacuation notices that went out. They clearly were not planning
for this. And actually that's a major indictment of our current
force projection as well. Is it's pretty clear and Donald Trump
said this. He said they were surprised by the attacks on the
bases, which is shocking because I think you knew that was going
to happen. I knew that was going to happen. They only need to
read open source and read a little bit of what the Iranians themselves
were saying. They were like, "Hey, here's the plan. If this happens,
this is what we're going to do." And he said that they were surprised
by that. And now a million Americans are stuck. Ambassador Mike
Huckabee, who by the way supposedly cares so much about Americans.
I saw his guidance for Americans in Israel trying to get out.
He was like, "Take a bus to the Sinai and hopefully you can catch
a flight from there." That's insane. It's like a 5 or 6-hour
bus ride, which they're not even really arranging, and that they
would take to the Sinai Peninsula, and then I even read a story
of a pregnant woman who had to do all of that. You know, imagine
the stress of all while this is happening. You take five, six
flights to be able to come home. These are our people. These
are the people that we're supposed to care about. And so, it's
just so tragic, you know, thinking you're talking about Juan
Beauty. What you're trying to recognize and paint for a picture
Oh, man. Not everybody
is as privileged as us to be able to go all across the world.
These are not, you know, these are not, you know, evil incarnate
gray, black, white photos. These are real places with real people.
They have different opinions. Some of them hate us, some of them
love us. They have very disparate histories and and identities,
religions. They're beautiful in the same way that all all humans
are really are beautiful in all places that we can find something
to appreciate about them. And so, I think that's what's tragic.
Things around the world are moving so fast right now. >> Shut
up, Tucker. >> I mean, anyone who's been in the Middle
East can tell you, I mean, they're, you know, they're great places
and they're terrible places, but some of these places, Amman,
Jordan, it's one of the great places in the world. Some unbelievable.
Doha at night? I mean, they're, you know, I don't want to go
on about it, but let me just say, I mean, it's this is
>> Doesn't Tucker own a property in Doha now? Didn't he
buy like a condo in Doha or something? >> You know, great
things are being destroyed. And and this is, I was thinking this
morning, kind of the last last gift of the boomers. You know,
wars
that are planned by that same generation which really did kind
of diminish the United States in in the space of just 50
nothing worth Dude, this is like I saw this and I'm like, bro,
Tucker is the weirdest chameleon.
This is the final gift of the boomers. It's like, bro, you are
like 2 years away from being a boomer.
Like, I think he's right at the edge of Gen X, technically.
But like,
>> does anyone else hate boomers? Guys, what's the deal
with boomers? Don't they
Shut up, Tucker. Shut the [__] Shut
You didn't hate the boomers when you like proselytizing to them
on Fox News all day. You didn't hate them when they were getting
you a million-dollar-a-year salary, did you, Tucker? Now you
hate them? Now that it's popular to do so, Tucker? Shut up. >> I
mean, they really took so much and gave so little. I I think
this is the kind of war you could only have between people of
advanced age. I I was thinking >> I totally agree with
you. And you know, you let's even take some of the talking points.
You're older than me, so this might resonate with you, but everybody
says this has been happening for 47 years. Remember 1979? I'm
33 years old. My mother was 15 in 1979, okay? So, 1979 to me
is a history book. 1979 is Argo, the movie. That's about as close
as I've got to the Iranian Revolution. I'm much closer to the
destruction of my country at the hands of the neocons of Iraq
and Afghanistan. I watch my cohort being unable to buy houses.
I watch relative people who are younger who are terrified of
AI. I have friends who are having their electricity bills go
up as a result of data centers. I've watched my own city, you
know, Washington D.C., which you and I have spent a lot of time
in go downhill every single year that I've lived in it, which
is shocking, right? And to watch literally that happen, and then
meanwhile I get on planes and I go visit Tokyo or Doha or Singapore
or Bangalore, any of these places which had a lot of problems
and still do, but have gotten a lot nicer. Whereas where I'm
living continues to tick down. So, 1979 I can appreciate as an
American, especially for a lot of the boomers, I get >> This
is like the This is where we do the black pill here. It's like,
hey,
all of the I I ton of basically all educated work can be farmed
any out anywhere in the world. There's really no barriers to
it at all. Um your country facilitates like not just outsourcing,
but also bringing in like skilled laborers who can also, you
know, drive wages down. There's no reason the American standard
of living is getting better. Like there's no element of any part
of American life that you could look at and go, "Here's why I
think the American standard of living is getting better in the
next 10 years."
It's only it's trajectory is going downwards no matter what angle
you take on it. So, that's why I I don't know like in terms of
like politics with no major shift, it's just total managed decline.
And I don't know like something's got to change, right? I I just
think Americans are going to continue to get filled like fed
up with it and eventually just vote for something crazy. We'll
see which way which way they go.
They could go left, they could go right. Seems like they're more
have a higher proclivity to break right. I don't know. >> Get
it. >> Do you guys Who who do you want to be your fascist
leader? Who do you guys think, you know, Republican in in terms
of who's your Republican Mussolini right now? I feel like that's
the only direction this is going. >> It must have been
so horrible and shocking and to be honest, to be fair, I also
think that the way the media covered that at the time they acted
like the revolution just happened out of nowhere. They don't
have enough of the know-how to go back to Mossadegh and the political
revolution and the CIA and much of the meddling that we also
did in that country. Not to mention the disaster of Jimmy Carter.
But I empathize with them for their hatred, let's say, of Iran
and their knowledge or you know, or looking at it as an enemy.
But I would also ask them to to give us the same empathy. Is
to look at us in the country that we have grown up in and they're
now raising children in my case and are saying, "I am looking
at
>> There's no reason to accept that as the United States.
That could be the case for other Western countries. As the United
States, you have enough power that you could leverage yourselves
out of that. But you're basically that would require cutting
into a profits for like huge companies and stuff and cutting
into the profits and applying pressure in a way that isn't just
making Donald Trump rich, right? But that can't happen, I guess.
I don't know why. >> as an explicit not only distraction,
but coming directly at the expense of a lot of problems, which
I care a lot about on behalf of my family, on behalf of the people
who are around me and for them, I don't see any benefit from
this. >> Well, that's for sure. So, now I want to ask you
about the effect on American politics. I mean, it feels like
in the last week, you know, was as as the Secretary of State
said something out loud that the day before would have been denounced
as anti-Semitic conspiracy theory. Israel made us do it. He said
that and it's true. I can I can verify that. That's true. And
now everyone's seen it. And so like where do we go? The the kidnapper
has pulled off his mask. So what does that mean? Now that we
know >> back from here. We are not going back. That's for
sure. Republicans are in a tough spot. So let's look at the evolution
of just the Democratic Party in the last 48, 72 hours. I'm watching
Ruben Gallego, Mark Warner, who is like a national security Democrat,
whatever that means who are like wow.
>> Literally, right? Like as you and I know. And he's talking
about how we're, you know, the dog, the tail is wagging the dog
and we can't be acting on behalf of Israel. Gavin Newsom, the
governor of California, who months ago twisted himself into a
knot to avoid saying a word AIPAC and couldn't even talk about
their influence on politics, just said he understands why people
would call Israel an apartheid state and how we may have to question
our relationship with that country. So that the dam has broken
on the Democratic side. >> Can I just ask you to pause?
What are the chan- I've watched all of this uh with my jaw open.
What are the chances Gavin Newsom called the ADL and AIPAC first
before he said that and said, "Hey guys, I just want to give
you a heads
>> And I'm going to performatively attack
>> Almost certainly 100%, but >> Dude, the Tucker
laughs, man. >> Newsom called the ADL and AIPAC first before
he said that and said, "Hey guys, I just want to give you a heads
up. >> And I'm going to performatively attack
>> Almost certainly 100%, but the attack still matters.
>> I mean >> matters and right >> Here's I
I just love that I love that Segarra is just immediately like
you're Segarra and then he's just immediately
Yeah, I'm sure that did happen. Like not even really questioning
it. Yeah, I know, he probably he probably called
>> Like you're right. >> He he does get so red. Dude,
you you notice the shift. Hold on. Look. Look. Look. That's 10
seconds
He's going red everywhere. He going beat red. Okay.
Or AIPAC would even allow that to happen if that were the case
is still shocking. I mean, even AIPAC has made changes in a lot
of their funding where they're allowing funding to go to some
Democrats even who are at least on the surface level who are
opposed to them. But if that's the Overton window that we all
now live in as a country, we can literally never go back to even
the 2024 status quo. >> But this is where the Republican
Party is very I look, I think they're in a very tough spot. Imagine
the amount of messaging, let's say that someone would start to
come out about how Trump doesn't care about your gas pri- I mean,
it's not just messaging, it's literally true. Uh the president
said basically, you know, high prices it it's so be it. And even
in terms of dead Americans, it said something along the lines
of you know, it happens there are casualties in war. These comments
are going to be wall-to-wall. I remember '06 vividly. It was
actually the first election which I really paid very close attention
to and lived through. I'm sure you do as well. Just remember
how the Democrats destroyed the George W. Bush party. And then
let's look at the structural problems that we already have. We
have the economic problems I already mentioned, bad jobs report
as of this morning, potential high gas prices just like back
in the mid-2000s. You were going and then you have people, senators
like Ted Cruz on your show, Mike Huckabee, members of our government
who are talking about the third temple. I mean, that's insane.
You're like, you're talking about third temple and red >> I'm
out here trying to pay my bills,
>> Ted, there's no way there's no way Mike Huckabee talked
about the third temple or a red heifer.
There's just no possible way.
There's no I got to I got to pull that Huckabee interview. There's
no way that Huckabee said that. Bro, okay. Socrates just made
that [__] up. That [__] the Socrates
just made that [__] up. That [__] didn't
happen in this interview. So, Socrates just brought up the third
temple and the red heifers for
And then he blamed it on the Huckabee interview. What? >> potential
high gas prices just like back in the mid-2000s. You were going
and then you have people, senators like Ted Cruz on your show,
Mike Huckabee, members of our government who are talking about
the third temple. I mean, that's insane. You're like, you're
talking about third temple and red heifers. I'm out here trying
to pay my bills, man. And then you can just watch how this is
going to erode the entire Republican Party, especially whatever
it comes to turnout. Now, but I do also want to be clear, and
you lived through this as well. The Bush I grew up in Bush country.
The Bush dead-enders, they stuck with him with 5,000 American
troops dead. So, there are a lot of Republicans who will stick
with President Trump throughout this war. They revere and they
trust him, and that's their right. They can do so. But, here's
what I always try to say. Republicans are not the reason that
Donald Trump won the 2024 election. He won with a wide coalition
of young people, of Latino voters, of a lot of independents,
and those people I can attest to you this 100% because a lot
are watching this show, my show, all the time. They have turned
on this president. They are furious about not just this war with
Iran, but a lot of
>> Breaking Points video. Breaking Points video and the
Red Heifers. Okay. Dude, Saagar is getting way too conspiracy
pill'd, okay?
>> Mike Johnson became the first House Speaker to visit
the occupied West Bank this week with a trip that has attracted
intense scrutiny. While there, he said that the mountains of
Judea and Samaria, the settlers' name for the West Bank, belong
to Israel by right, which not only contradicts internet
>> I'm not. I can't. I just I can't. I can't watch that.
I can't watch that. What is this Red Heifer thing?
Um it's some prophecy they have that when you slaughter the Red
Heifer, there's some ritual they do, and when you kill this Red
Heifer, it's supposed to usher in the apocalypse.
Like I think it's it's one of It might be one of the steps before
Revelations. But, they were they were supposed to be doing like
they used to do like fake versions of this cuz they genuinely
believe it will happen. And then I believe just recently they
had a they accidentally did a real Red Heifer. I
>> different things up to this point. And at this point,
I mean, we are going into a territory where it's not just about
the war with Iran, it's about how many clips I've played some
of them on my own show of members of this cabinet, members of
this administration, who spoke explicitly about why war with
Iran is not in our interest. And it's one of those things that's
like the Epstein files. What people see inside of them is when
you cover that up, I can't trust you about anything else. And
same with war and peace. I mean, we're we're literally playing
with people's lives. And you've spoken very eloquently about
the reason Washington loves this is because they believe that
they are God. Is it the power of God for life and death in upon
them makes them feel bigger from whatever sad life, you know,
that they came from. And they've been subsumed by that now with
power. And they are going to get a rude reminder of what that
looks like in the midterm elections if things go in a if these
all go in a rat radically different radically different direction.
Watching that play out in Texas or watching that play out all
across the country with Democratic turnout. And look, you know,
even in a self-interested perspective, for a lot of these Trump
officials, you know, if you don't want millions of dollars in
legal bills and house subpoenas for the rest of your life, for
the rest of your natural life, let me be clear, you might want
to be start to do something very different than what you're doing
right now. >> So as I said, um >> To be honest, I
need I need rapid expansion of the Overton window, okay?
Some people have to end their political careers right now.
Just calling for
oh, what is it?
Tribunals, okay? Tribunals. We need tribunals is what we need,
okay? Marmaduke, 500 kicks? >> a complete and total shutdown
of Christian Zionists in this country until we can figure out
what the hell is going
>> Absolutely, yeah. You do.
I need I need people on the right and the left to start calling
for tribunals cuz it's like literally we're going to go through
your finances. You're going to have to You're going to show us
that you weren't just making massive amounts of money doing what
you've been doing.
Cuz that's
These guys are like oh, you know,
Stogner's talking about oh, you know, we're we're going to subpoena
you. You're going to be under house subpoena. No, no, no, no,
no.
You're going to be buried under the house, okay? That's I need
I need people
opening up that end. It needs to It needs to Somebody has to
start arguing it so we believe that things will actually happen.
And yes, some people will lose their YouTube accounts.
The sacrifice I'm willing to make is somebody without one, okay?
But somebody needs to start arguing for
Cuz I swear like as long as it's just as long as the furthest
people are willing to go is just saying we're going to we're
going to subpoena you, okay?
That's not far enough. That's not even close to far enough. And
if unless the window starts expanding, it's never going to never
going to catch up, never going to sorry, it's never going to
catch on, it's never going to get >> I flew to DC three
times in the last month to try to convince Trump not to do this.
It didn't work. It happens. I'm looking at this and I'm thinking,
boy, this is not going to get better. So then I think I'll fly
up again and ask him. I mean, I don't know if anyone else is
doing this, so I'm going to try to just declare victory and go
home. Like you killed an 86-year-old cleric, let's just call
that a win and and then pull back. And so then meantime he he
got convinced to denounce me, okay? I I don't care. I'm going
to fly up anyway and see him, right? Even though he's like denouncing
me. So I call over there to see, you know, call someone who knows
him to see I said I'm just going to fly up anyway and and tell
him this because I think it's so important. And the person says,
don't bother because
he's being shown polling that this war is like a 90/10 win for
him. And I said, I don't know where that polling is coming from.
It's like I you know, I guess you can make any kind of poll and
it's he's watching Fox News which is telling him the same thing
and he's getting fake polling. I guess they're only polling Sean
Hannity's viewers or something. And so I don't know I'm not sure
that there's a sense as if this was yesterday cuz I was getting
so agitated and
I don't think that there's a sense that this is unpopular.
Like I think there's an information vacuum here. >> There's
an massive information
Wait, you're telling me Donald Trump has a unique ability to
just totally ignore reality? You don't say.
That's I've never heard of that before. >> vacuum and you
know for the president and the administration who declared victory
based on internet and vibes and podcasts, let's take a survey,
shall we, of every podcast that he appeared on and how do they
feel about the Iran conflict? You can you can look very clearly
for yourself. You can look at a lot of the polling of that same
demographic which they were very excited about, young men in
particular, how are they feeling about this conflict? And you
know, if you were saying 90/10, it's not even true in a Republican
sense. I mean, the latest one that I saw was like 72% Republicans,
which by the way, Mr. President and everybody in the administration,
Bush had 93 for Iraq, and how did that turn out for him? So,
let's not put, you know, put all of our eggs in the basket of
just because Republican voters are here that this is all going
to be like sunshine and roses. And I also would not make the
spurious claim that it's all about Iran. It's about compounding
effects. The gas price effect of the Iran conflict is going to
be dramatically more important to the White House's political
chances in the midterms than anything that's actually happening
on the ground. I don't think it should be that way, but that's
reality. And I do think also, you're you're you're >> Those
midterms are gone. I don't think I don't think anyone in the
Trump administration is even thinking about the midterms anymore.
They know those midterms are gone. That that ship has >> Iraq,
your inclination to get him to try and declare victory, that's
the correct move from strategic perspective, and economic perspective,
from every political perspective. You don't want the entire country's
national discourse focused on Iran. I'll give you a good example.
Just yesterday, the White House did a summit where they were
trying to address rising electricity prices on data centers.
In another world, no Iran, that's a main topic of conversation
on my show. A major topic. Maybe one of yours interests as well.
But in the middle of war and peace and death and everything that's
happening, the amount of coverage that got is zero. The president
just gave his State of the Union. He had a lot of things in that
State of the Union. Iran, what, it didn't come until the 70th
minute, I think? What was the rest of it about? The economy,
about gas prices, about jobs. Mr. President and others, like,
that's what people really vote on. And so, there's also in Washington
and in media, there is literally a zero sum whenever it comes
to people's attention, the news's attention, media. And it's
not like we're doing the wrong thing. Matters of war and peace
are unironically more important than data center electricity
potential plans. But if you want people to be even acknowledge
that you're focusing on those types of things, you cannot be
having foreign adventurism run amok in the Middle East and be
declaring things like unconditional surrender, which is going
to be the headline of every major news, you know, every news
organization in America. You know, whenever we're going to make
Iran great again, whether you're pro or anti, that's all people
are going to be talking about for the foreseeable future. Not
to mention oil prices and just I mean the sheer industry of bombs
literally flying >> Wait, where did this happen, Canadian
caller? This wasn't in the news thing today. What are you talking
about there? >> Uh when you realize a lot of geopolitics
in the Middle East is all based on fictional religious scripture,
you really stop caring about the whole
>> Why? Why would you stop caring? That's not a sign to
stop caring. It's a sign to start screaming.
It's Bro, I I'm totally fine with people being religious. Just
don't destroy the global economy because you're religious.
God helps those who help themselves. You're not helping yourself.
These people are dragging you all down. >> Fine. That's
right. >> over people's head.
>> So, big picture, and again, I'm always rooting for the
United States and its president, no matter who it is. In the
case of this president, I know him really well for many years,
and I I'll always like him. I don't care what he says about me.
Um I will always have affection for him,
>> but I also think, if you think about it, like this is
the end of something. Voters take a guy from completely outside
the political system cuz they're so frustrated with the system,
and they like him or don't like him or whatever, but it's the
system that is on trial here, and the system has been found wanting.
It It doesn't actually respond to voters in the way that it should.
It's not improving the country. So, they bring this guy from
completely outside the system to shock the system and to tame
it, to drain the swamp, and now I think we can say that that
failed. And so, what now? >> Yeah, that's uh Well, we have
a bit more years to go. I put a book behind me, the George W.
Bush book, and it gave me no pleasure to do so because of the
parallels I'm watching already to '04 to '08. Let's think about
it. We've got a squishy economy >> with some problems.
We've got a Middle Eastern conflict, potential energy crisis.
We have an AI potential bubble which could part pop at any moment.
We have Democrats who are rad- radically enthused with no leader
at the top, meaning they get to have an open debate in their
party. They can say things that are a lot more honest than the
person who has a leader at the top of their party. They can have
real function, and they can actually debate things out in the
open. And it's very healthy for a political party, and that's
exactly how the Democrats really ascended from power from 2004,
the failed John Kerry campaign, to winning what 55% of the vote
under Barack Obama. That was a very good process for them. Well,
I'm watching it all play out step by step by step, and it's very
similar, like you just said about the revolution. There's a revolutionary
aspect to the Donald Trump campaign. The second one, more so
than the first, in my opinion, and affirmed, I think, with the
popular vote, where it truly was revolutionary in terms of it
You have this president, he'd been president before. I mean,
literally, like he almost was almost assassinated. There were
all of these potential indictments against him. You know, the
imagery, the sheer, like, imagery and idea of somebody like that
being able to send, again, to the highest office of the land,
is insane. And then, in the initial moments, you have Dodge,
and you have, you know, people you would never see in power,
like RFK Jr. here, and Tulsi Gabbard, and Pete Hegseth. There
was a real excitement for an Orrin Hatch Patel origin or that
at that point, not at this point. But, these people were seen
as revolutionary actors who were going to come in and throw a
bomb inside of the system. But, then, if you watch the US government
do the exact same thing that it did under all these past presidents,
your revolution starts to look a lot more like the status quo,
which was deeply hated and which you exploited to your great
political benefit, and >> I mean, yeah, obviously. It's
the It's the exact same thing. Very, very obviously.
Hold on.
The Wall Street Journal had an article out today describing how
this from yesterday, how Lindsey Graham plays toddler memory
games with Trump and coaches Netanyahu on things to say to in
order to get Trump to do some more war. No shot.
Lindsey Graham's quest to sell Trump on striking Iran. Few others
in the president's ear argued for attack as effectively as the
South Carolina
As Lindsey Graham tried to sell Donald Trump on bombing Iran,
he liked to play a little word associating association game with
the president. I say Franklin Roosevelt, what do you say? The
Republican senator from South Carolina asked. The correct answer,
you have nothing to fear but fear
As he ticked through memorable presentation presentation presidential
phrases, Graham asked Trump what his phrase would be. Trump said
he didn't know. Graham recalled, keep protesting, help is on
the way. Graham suggested, referring to Trump's social media
post in January urging Iranians to confront their government.
Help make the case on Iran, Graham traveled several times to
Israel in recent weeks meeting with members of the country's
intelligence agency. They'll tell me things our own government
won't tell me, he said. He spoke with Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu coaching him on how to lobby the president
for action. Netanyahu showed the president intelligence that
persuaded Trump to go ahead, Graham
Kill Lindsey
in a video game in a video game in a video game. Tribunals
for Lindsey Graham.
Tribunals, tribunals, court court making decisions, process process
process process. We do process here. Process,
Oh my goodness.
Yes, treasonous treasonous actions from Lindsey Graham.
My god, man.
>> Right now, I am watching the same type of revolutionary
aspect take place in the Democratic Party. And if you want >> If
Asim Gold could say this about random protesters, I should be
able to say it about Lindsey Graham, okay? >> part of that
and not to just be run over in future elections. They need to
get wise very very quickly. I I wonder, I mean, since all kinds
of things have happened in the last 2 years that no one ever
could have predicted. Like really really radical things from
Trump being shot in Butler, Pennsylvania to right now, a week
ago, the United States declaring war on, you know, unprovoked
with no direct provocation in the middle of negotiations with
Iran. Like even though it was happening, it was still a shock
that it actually
Since we have a very recent track record of really unusual, if
not radical, things happening. I mean, how like how concerned
should we be in the United States about something like really
radical happening here and not just a terror attack or as likely
a false flag terror attack or whatever, Americans being killed
in America, which is what matters. But like the US government
doing something crazy. How should we feel about criticism of
this war or Americans who criticize the war from within the United
States, at risk, do you think? >> Let's just be honest.
>> It terrifies me. It terrifies me. It >> I mean,
I, dude.
>> I'm surprised, quite frankly, that Nick Fuentes is alive.
Tucker feels I feel I honestly just expect, you know, I feel
like I expect one of these two people out of out of Tuckers and
Fuentes to just like be gone one day. Just like disappear. I
swear I swear I feel like it'll be like, "Oh, there's a tragic
car accident." Okay. >> Let's be honest, Glenn. You should
be honest because Well, let's look at the Department of Homeland
Security, right? And we you and I can be supportive of a lot
of the president's immigration policy. And I think we can also
recognize that there were parts of that immigration policy which
were specifically directed by a foreign lobby for trying to deport
people who are critical of the nation-state of Israel. Sorry,
I didn't care about that. That was literally like a function
of like the Department of Anti-Racism effectively coming in becoming
the Department of Anti-Semitism [laughter] as floated by Ibram
X. Kendi. That was the level of insanity that we saw when people
were getting deported for writing an op-ed. Okay. Well, now this
machinery has a new uh potential lead, He's very pro-Israel.
Uh well, also, let's see, that could get, you know, marched and
created into an organism where already, you know, I've seen calls
for people who are critical of the war, you know, should be silenced,
should be subpoenaed. I think I saw that one about you. They
said that you should be subpoenaed and dragged before the >> I
should be imprisoned. Yeah. >> Right. Imprisoned, right?
Didn't somebody say you should even be put into an internment
camp? This is how it all happened, guys. I mean, this is how
it all happened. The Pearl Harbor to internment camps for Japanese
was like this. It was a blink of an eye, within a year-long period.
That's how it happened. We were stripped all of these Americans
of their fundamental rights and locked them in a camp. That's
insane. So, the idea that it could never happen is obviously
proven by our own history that it very obviously could. But more
importantly, it will look like in a 21st century way. So, there
will be AI, there's already mass censorship, there's mass bots
and propaganda efforts that are going on right now. I mean, already,
how difficult is it to even see various types of video uh which
is coming out from the actual conflict trying to verify whether
any of this is even real in real time as we're processing what's
happening. But I think what you raise is if you look at every
war as for America, especially the wars of my lifetime, the war
on terror, I am fundamentally less free today than I was as a
child born in the United States in 1992. And the Americans who
lived through Vietnam were less free after the Vietnam war than
they were before. And the Americans who were born or the Americans
in World War were less free in many respects or especially during
the war for censorship rules and all of the stuff that the government
was doing than before the outbreak of the war and then before
that with World War I. And Civil War, too. I mean, think about
suspension of habeas corpus Dude. Dude. Dude. Dude. What's up,
Los Pollos? Dude.
Since the invasion, oil prices have skyrocketed. Today, the average
gas price in America hit an all-time record high of over $4 per
gallon. Okay, that stinks, but a clear conscience is worth a
buck or two. This is By the way, they they've got a new catchphrase,
okay? The thing they started saying recently is short-term pain
for long-term gain. Guys, this is a little short-term pain for
long-term gain. If you want to know, okay, if you ever
I hate
Uh
short-term pain for long-term gain. What are we gaining again?
Who's to say?
Peace of mind for Israel. That's what you're gaining, okay? Dude,
it's
This is crazy. Short-term oil prices, which will drop rapidly
when the destruction of Iran's nuclear threat is over, is a very
small price to pay for USA and world safety and peace. Only fools
would think differently. President
Nobody likes you. Nobody likes you. Nobody likes you. Nobody
likes you. Nobody likes you. Nobody likes you. This is Oh, this
one is tough, man.
Yeah, Canadian caller, I said the first night, I was like, "Bro,
oil not only oil because of Iran, but oil because it's a hedge
against inflation."
And stuff's going to inflate really
I I still think I think oil at $110 a barrel is still like a
a steal.
I'm not even joking. I think it's going up way higher. I I do.
I think it's going to like way higher than this, for sure.
But, yeah, we'll see.
No, I think I Dude,
I genuinely feel like 200 is not out of the realm of possibility.
Just look at how much infla- stuff is inflated, okay? I think
people don't understand how much stuff is inflated, like how
much prices have inflated, and oil is barely hitting places where
it has hit before.
Like oil has hit higher than this.
200 is global collapse? I don't think so. Why? Why would it be
global collapse
at $200? I mean, I don't think it's going to stay there. That
will cause enough pain that things will change, right? Dude,
did you guys see the Billy Bob Thornton? There's like some Billy
Bob Thornton show where he like talks
There's like a quote where he's like, "Oh, yeah, you don't want
You don't want oil over $100 a barrel. You can't sell it for
that much."
It's like something where he's like specifically like an oil
baron or What the [__] is this [__] Land
man, yeah, land man.
He like ex- He like throws it out. It's a It's just a show. It
doesn't really mean anything, but I just thought it was funny
that it's like
You don't want it too high. You don't want it too low. You don't
want it too
Go gangbusters at $75 a barrel. I think he said 74.
It's great show. Never watched it. Just saw the clip. Thought
it was
China's laughing at us with their EVs right now. Dude, their
EVs are so cool, too. Their EVs are like super nice,
No, it was It was land man. >> All of these different things
that these presidents have done. It is a natural effect for a
wartime nation to crack down on speech, and specifically critical
speech of those war efforts. And they should be afraid. Even
if you like the person who is in power, you need to recognize
that this is a historical trend, which goes back through our
entire history. It's part of the reason I think that you and
I abhor war so much. And we also, this is the scariest part,
is this is when you watch this censorship be self-imposed on
media organizations and you create a system and an incentive
structure such that criticizing the war will remove, you know,
any professional ability that you may have to advance yourself.
Specifically, let's say as a policy maker in Washington. You
and I know dozens of people who are in power, they don't support
this war and they can't say anything out of fear of losing their
job. I'm not just talking about in the White House, I'm talking
about in the entire, you know, national security apparatus, the
think tanks or others because they're afraid, you know, of either
being called by the donors or for saying that you're being too
critical of something that the president supports. Open debate
and free speech, the inability to have any of that in the lead
up to Iraq destroyed our nation. It destroyed it. I'm very committed
to making sure that doesn't happen again, but you and I are very
we're individuals and the US government is a leviathan and we
should be wary of it. >> Are are you I mean, as someone
and I this is not flattery, but it's sincere. You're one of the
very first people to see this realignment in American politics.
I mean, 10 years ago. You saw it very clearly and you staked
your whole career on it and you were right and that's why you've
been successful, I would say. So, it's worth listening to your
prediction, I think, on this question. Do you see
>> Did is the full episode of Pete Hegseth on 60 Minutes?
Is that out? Is the full interview out? Like I'm seeing new clips
from the interview. Is it finally out? >> a crackdown on
civil liberties, human rights in the United States coming up.
It because of this war, the war is a pretext for what was already
in the plans, but do you see that happening? >> I could
see it easily happening and we already have the machinery as
we saw with Israel criticism and the so-called Department of
Anti-Racism. I've raised several cases to you, Tucker, of the
Department of Justice getting involved in like campus incidents,
which is insane, by the way. I opposed that under Obama. I opposed
that under Biden. I oppose it now. I'm going to stick to my principles.
The machinery for that is already laid and it is one that should
really terrify us and you and I are in a unique position we can
speak out. I don't really care about myself. I care about the
individual person who is well >> Oh, also the thing about
it costing money to make EVs is that China has like a lot of
stationary renewable energy product projects. So, like they can
do things like
build solar, nuclear, wind reactor, like different power stations
around their like production infrastructure.
And you don't have to spend like fossil fuels on that stuff,
right? So, while it costs a lot of energy to make those cars,
to go through the processes to make the batteries and stuff,
you can set that up when you're a command economy or like a borderline
command economy.
And it's not quite so bad.
Like basically you have to use that energy, especially anything
like solar, you'd have to use it. Although I don't I actually
don't know how much China uses solar. But I'm assuming that's
what a lot of their nuclear power
has been set up to do, right? To power their their uh what would
you say? What do you call it? I was going to say their production
grid, but like their manufacturing space.
You know what I'm saying? >> relatively powerless with
200 or so followers getting a knock on the door by the FBI saying,
"Hey, why did you say this? What did you mean?" >> Just
need lots of children to run the mines. Well, that's why they
go to Africa. That's the what Belt and Road Initiative was all
about, okay? >> mean by that. And that very level of harassment
is chilling. Not to mention at institutional level, who knows?
I mean, will the government find people Look at Look at the situation
with Anthropic and Claude, right? I mean, you have this showdown
between the Pentagon and Anthropic over the use of AI, their
technology in a time of war, demands over human oversight. The
government's basically saying that's unacceptable. You don't
get to dictate those terms to us. They can blacklist you as a
company, literally blacklist you for not agreeing to those terms.
That's fine, that's their right. But think >> Hold on.
>> about that. I mean, they're basically saying that not
only are they not going to use it at all, they're going to blacklist
you from all US government contractors, which is massively massively
impactful to their entire business. This can happen across the
board. And you can look at Look at the CBS acquisition right
now with Barry Weiss in charge of CBS News. Censorship doesn't
just happen. And that you know, censorship and reduction civil
liberty does not just happen at the government level. Corporate
censorship, corporate power can be just as much of a threat to
your individual liberty as the government power. >> I mean,
this is the last English-speaking country, probably the last
country in the world in which attitudes have not yet been criminalized
at least officially, but Australia, New Zealand, Canada, every
country in Europe, you're not allowed to have certain attitudes,
you can go to jail. Like your opinions are crimes. They are literally
thought crimes. And I just noticed cuz I've been at the center
of it, this effort over the past year to criminalize attitudes.
And when I was first called an anti-Semite, I remember thinking,
well, I'm I'm actually not, and so I don't know why you're calling
me that. And I was annoyed or whatever, but the insistence with
which these forces are labeling people with the slander anti-Semite,
it doesn't seem accidental. I don't really think it's not air
if you're an anti-Semite or not. I mean, Israel's very close
to the Zelensky government, which supports actual Nazis. So,
like, they don't care if you're an anti-Semite. This is an effort
to set the stage for prosecutions. That's what I'm starting to
think. Do you think that's too too paranoid? >> No, not
at all. Well, first of all, we have literally deported people
for being critical of Israel. >> Well, you should you should
know that a lot of their stuff's been from coal just because
of the smog problems they have,
But I thought that was like basically they're they're doing this
and they're trying to move basically from
some more efficient power plant structures. They're going from
coal to jumping directly into like nuclear and I would have like
nuclear power plants take forever to build. I would imagine they
don't have a lot of the infrastructure built that they started
even like 10 years ago, let alone five.
They take forever to build. >> That actually happened already
under this government. We are having the Department of Justice,
the Attorney General get involved in campus incidents around
so-called anti-Semitism. That is the machine and the groundwork
which could be laid for exactly what you're talking about. But
then let's look. We recognize this. If you live through the woke
revolution, let's think about the way that this works now with
so-called anti-Semitism. As they accuse you, it's all about escalation.
So, first, you're being defined as an anti-Semite. And where
your words and comments, what do they say? That you're trying
to incite violence against a specific organization. Incitement
of violence is actually a very specific term. So, what does that
mean? An imminent threat, which means that they want to be able
to have an FBI agent come and knock on your door to ask you either
to clarify what you're asking about or potentially prosecute
you for your alleged comments that are around this. Each one
is a step in a ground to make sure and to lay the groundwork
to make it so that such a case could eventually be brought and
in an insane time. And when we have Look, we're at the very beginnings
of this conflict. Who knows how long it goes. I pray it just
ends. But again, all through history, it only usually gets worse
whenever it comes to censorship and demands. I mean, already
this entire conversation, you and I know, will be branded as
anti-Semitic and pro-Iran. These are meaningless, ridiculous
terms, but they will be pumped as propaganda into entire ecosystem
to smear and to define us both as individuals. And then from
there, we'll be start to talking about treason, right? So very
recently I'll give you a great example. During the outbreak of
uh Russia and of Ukraine, we had an incident, I think it
>> I'm telling you 200 is not I'm telling you 200 is not
outside the realm of possibility.
I'm just telling you it's not.
It's just straight-up not. It's literally it's You'd have to
be crazy cuz Yeah, I know. I know. I know what it is, Turikat.
I'm
People just don't get that Destiny spoke to Pisco defending Hot
I think earlier. Yeah, I don't care. I I get covered. I just
don't Unless it's like interesting, I don't give a I've no idea
what you're talking about,
Um yeah. Okay.
Oh, I was going to say basically like the way financial markets
are set up, speculation runs wild really fast, and I think people
are seeing that there's no end in sight right now. And it's just
not that weird to
to think that you're going to like
it's just going to keep going. It's going to keep getting worse.
There's no reason not to speculate and buy at higher and higher
prices cuz there's just no end in sight.
Yeah. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. >> What's with YouTube?
Where they banned all Russian state media. And I would make a
case to them behind the scenes. I said, "Guys, I'm not pro-Russian,
but if we're in the middle of a war, which, you know, ostensibly
we're not even in, shouldn't I be able to cover what's going
on in Russia? Which, yes, has a state media, but they put out
things from Vladimir Putin. Should I not be allowed to play things
from Vladimir Putin?" But never really had any answer to that.
I I used to deal with that with Donald Trump. So, back in 2021,
they had a policy where even if you played a clip of Donald Trump
saying that the election was stolen, some say in 2021, they would
take down that video. And I would say, "Guys, I have to cover
the news. He's going to run for president. I you know, I can
give commentary on his clips, but that is how quickly the censorship
machine can act." And especially, now we're watching here with
the intertwining of regulators and of these big companies, if
you start to put pressure like that, you could see it so that
even with the government not directly trying to censor you for
your comments. But, >> Dude, am I the only person who's
like
like I don't use that much gas? Like if even if I had to pay
like double for gas, not double,
maybe I'd consider it if it was double. But like it costs me
like 60 Canadian to fill my tank. Cuz I got a like a very fuel-efficient
vehicle, not that big of a gas tank on
and like even if I had to go pay like 50% more, it's not worth
me like running to the gas station to do it.
You never leave your house. Never What the I left my house today.
What are you
What the What the I left my house today.
That's very rude. >> I literally just branding you anti-Semitic,
pro-Iran, or any of these things. You can watch your very ability
to speak out as a citizen of America be be eroded you know, or
evaporate or completely overnight. >> And and just to restate
like the foundational principle of the country, you have a right,
a God-given right not granted you by government, but with which
you were born, to have any opinion you want, to follow your own
conscience. You don't have a right to do anything you want, but
you have a right to believe anything you want and to say anything
that you want that you believe is true. Period. And so, >> Yeah,
so 147 is the highest it's ever been. People just aren't taking
into account how prices of everything have inflated. That like
realistically, if you take into account of inflation,
like we're not even really that high on oil price right now,
right? Like if you if you were to inflate it the same way all
goods have been inflated over the past like year and a half,
2 years. Sorry, not year and a half, 2 years. Last 5 years.
You go back, like it could go so much
Like think of how much more everything cost than it did in '08
when it hit 4 40 147. I really don't think 200's out outside
the realm of possibility. >> Oh, I I'm not pro-Iran. I've
never been to Iran and I'm surely not an anti-Semite at all.
However, any American has the right to preferences and beliefs,
religious beliefs, philosophical beliefs, political beliefs.
Those are absolute rights. Those are human rights. That's what
human rights are. >> Yes, oil prices increasing means the
cost of everything increases because everything needs to be transported.
Yes. Yes. Yes.
>> And so you can never prosecute someone >> Now,
just remember, I just want you to always remember when you feel
that rage, just know that this was done
so that Israel could feel secure, okay? No imminent attack on
anybody, but just it was done so Israel could feel secure. Just
remember, that's what your That's what your livelihood, your
well-being, your happiness was sacrificed for, all right? Just
keep that in mind every >> for having views you disagree
with. Period. And I I do think we have to stand up for that above
all else, right? Especially in wartime. In wartime, more important
than ever. And you know, again, I I watched this happen with
Iraq. I watched this happen with Afghanistan. I've read too much
about it from Vietnam, from World War I, from World War II, from
the Civil War. And I I literally based my entire career trying
to say this will never happen or if any if I have anything to
do with it, it won't happen again. And then it did happen again.
Uh and so then we have to set up for the next playbook. It's
okay, we know that they're coming. We know they're coming. So
we have to plan for that. The only way to plan for that is to
get the people who are on our side because fundamentally, you
know, again, it's not about us. It's about even it's really about
smaller private individuals who have literally the fundamental
right to say their whatever they want and to for them to be harassed.
We have to protect that more than anything. >> Yeah. I
don't know what's coming next, but I know that you're going to
be at the center of it. And I know you will understand it before
most people. So, I hope that you will come back. I really mean
that. I'm grateful for this. Thank you, Saagar Great to see you.
>> Thank you, Tucker. And thank you for everything that
you do and for giving me my own start in this business. I'll
always be so deeply thankful. >> Man, if I knew you were
as smart as you turned out to be, I would have paid you more.
You'd still be working [laughter]
>> That's true. I would have liked that, too. I would have
liked that. Thank you, >> Great to see you, man. Hey. >> Where
was Where was Saagar working that Tucker was paying him? The
What the Okay. All right.
That was That was not bad.